Hey guys, it's Justine and today, we're unboxing the new Apple HomePod. Yes here it is
I'm so excited about this. So you guys know that I'm a huge Apple fan
But I also love smart home tech. Anything that can help me simplify or control my home especially through my voice
I'm a huge fan of so let's get to the unboxing!
Oh! We've got a great little pull tab here, so I don't even need a knife
I even brought a few selections for today, but it looks like I'm not even gonna need these after all
Guess I'll put this away
Okay flip it around because you gotta see this!
[UNBOXING ASMR]
Here it is! It looks so good it fits my aesthetic perfectly
It smells - it doesn't really have a smell
It looks like we've got some little instructions. Oh, this is fantastic
They of course included a wonderful Apple sticker here
and it has a circular little cutout connect your Wi-Fi and turn on Bluetooth hold your device into the home pod and then complete the
On-screen setup all done now simply ask Siri to play music to learn more go to the tips set up your app
I love this extension cord unlike most
Apple cords and cables it more like that plasticky finish whereas this is sort of like a soft kind of fabricky feel Siri
Welcome to the iJustine household. You're gonna. Love it here. Ok it's plugged in something's happening
Hi hello
Okay, oh, it's happening. It's happening so it's asking me if I want to set up and yes
I do now it's asking me. Where is the home pot bathroom bedroom dining room garage?
Hallway, kitchen living room master bedroom office patio, and I guess I'm just gonna choose office for the sake of I'm in my office
Right now so the next screen is personal requests allow anyone to use this home pod to send and receive
Messages and reminders create notes and more with this iPhone when it's connected to the same Wi-Fi network
So you do have the option to turn this off so
potentially your friends could troll you and send and receive messages on your Siri home pod, but
I'm gonna enable it. I'll take my chances terms and conditions
Yes, I will agree so the screens the accounts and settings screen so basically what's gonna happen
Here is you're gonna be using your iCloud account Wi-Fi all of the settings that you have on your phone to configure your home pod
Hi, I'm Siri welcome to home, pod you can't tell but I'm waving to get my attention say hey Siri
Hey, try it Siri. Hey Siri. What can you do? Hey Siri?
What can you do I can do lots of things?
Like turn on the lights give you a news update and tell you about the weather now you try say hey Siri
Play some music. Hey Siri play some music okay
Here's a personal radio station, built just for you starting with Third Eye Blind
Remember any time you have a question just say hey Siri
I love this song it's almost like she knows me already
Hey Siri stop playing I'm gonna get a copyright strike, so I gotta be really careful
Hey, Siri. Play me some top 90s rock playing some 90s rock
Oh
Hey, Siri, what is this band this is EMF this track is called unbelievable. Hey Siri when was the song first released?
Unbelievable by iana came out on May 7th
Alexa stop playing oh my god. Oh my god. No, hey Siri stop playing
It was a mistake I didn't mean to say I'm so sorry to offend you
One of the upsides to home pod as opposed to other smart devices as this has a six microphone array so basically it can hear
You from very far distances or even while the music is playing
There is a lot of tech built into this little guy that we don't even see it features seven horn loaded tweeters right down here
At the bottom and at the top is actually where the high excursion
Woofer is that is where you're getting the crazy awesome bass at hey Siri
Do I have any new messages you have two new messages from Nick the Proterra digital touch message, that's my proof of life
Yes, what do you want to say, I'm
Texting you with my voice using the home pod right now. I am texting you with my voice using the home pod right now
Ready to send it yes
Hey, Siri
Text Jenna Ezarik and tell her that I am sending her a message
From my voice on the home pod your reply to jenna ezarik Fried egg
Says I am sending her a message from my voice on the home pod so my sister
I have a little fried egg emoji next her name, so that's why I said jenna ezarik fried egg
Do I have a new message you have three new messages for me. Oh
What are we on for tomorrow?
Cheeks, would you like to reply yes, we are still on for tomorrow to do some cooking videos
Well, let's tell you if I'm laughing or not
Yes, we are still on for tomorrow to do some cooking videos
Hey, Siri, turn the volume all the way. That's very loud. Are you sure?
Yes
OH MY GOSH THIS WHOLE DESK IS SHAKING
Hey siri Turn the volume at half
This is great. I'm having the best time. Hey siri stop playing
Play me some music. Okay. Let's press play
So as you can see there is little buttons here that show up so if you
Just press the volume down you can do that just like that so it's crazy about this isn't matter
Where you put your home pod it learns your space so in real time
It is processing the environment and what it should sound like so no matter where you are in this room
because of the speakers that are all around it you don't have to just be standing directly in front of it if I were to
Place this in the middle of my room
It would sound exactly the same no matter where I was standing
So the way that this processes sound is different depending upon where you place it because this right now is close to this wall
It is real-time configuring each speaker to give you the best listening experience
I am still so shocked turning this thing up all the way. There's no distortion at all
*music starts playing* NO OFF! HEY SIRI
Turn the volume all the way down Wow that scared me
I tapped the button, this is also touch sensitive, so if you do press down that will activate Siri
So she is listening right now as you can see I don't have that information all right you press down that bill. Yep, though
I was talking to my friends
Hey, Siri. Stop playing this thing's fast. It's really really fast
It's kind of difficult to give you guys a listening experience because everyone is listening to this video on different speakers or different systems
So there's really no possible way that this is gonna sound the same unless you actually experience it in person I'm gonna
Just tell you it sounds so good well guys
I just wanted to do a quick little unboxing for you
so you can see what's inside the box and how to get this thing all set up plus a few of my favorite features I
Love that you're able to actually have a conversation with Siri
Hey, siri, when was the song released weight of living part 2 by Bastille was released on March 4th
I think that's when I actually interview them as MTV event I did so the home quad
Obviously does work best with Apple music and that's because Apple has all of the information about these songs in their database
But that doesn't mean that you can't play anything else from Spotify or anything else from your phone with that
You'll just have to use airplay. Okay. I'll pick office
So that's great. Hey, Siri. What song is playing this is called scared to be lonely by Martin garrix
When was the song released scared to be lonely by Martin garrix was released on January 27
So there's a lot more that you can do with home pod, and I'm gonna go over that all in a separate video
But for now this was the unboxing and a quick first look at the home pod, honestly
I only was going to get one of them, but now after seeing it and playing with it
I definitely am getting more later
This year there will be a software update to allow you to use two of these and give you surround sound hey Siri play me
Some party music sure here's a personalized station of party songs
oh yeah, Calvin Harris
She knows me so well
Hey, Siri
Stop playing well. Thank you guys so much for watching my unboxing video
I have another full video testing out more of the features of the home pod once you're done watching this which is right now because
This is the end of the video go check that one out
I'll put a link in the description and annotation and a card, and I think you can figure out how to watch it
I'll see you there. Bye